so you may have heard of this game
called psychonauts it's getting a sequel
this year and it's just been added to
game pass
and you're probably wondering should i
play a 16 year old game from the ogx box
in 2021
the answer is obviously yes of course
you should
psychonauts is the quintessential
display of studio double fine's
imaginative and creative abilities that
is still
barely rivaled in triple a gaming today
and whether this is your first time or
just looking to replay it look no
further than its unabashed whimsiness
cast of weirdo characters and this
beautiful sea monster to prove it
and what name is that noble lake
creature
what a magical lady and i rest my case
[Music]
hold on i'm not actually done i haven't
even made my point yet
now yes it's very obvious that i have an
existing affinity towards this game but
it's also been
ages since i've last played it so when
the chance came to try it out once again
not only did i fall in love with it all
over but something else came to mind
psychonauts is kind of a big deal and
the fact that we're even getting a
sequel
a decade and a half later is sort of a
miracle
let me paint this picture it's 2005 an
eclectic year for games god of war
shadow of the colossus splinter cell
resident evil 4 and the one
that i was most excited for psychonauts
which had one thing that those other
games did not
this guy tim shafer tim brown directed
my favorite game of all time
grim fandango this is my signed copy of
grim fandango
dukert from tim i'm kurt
grimm fandango is a sprawling noir epic
set in the afterlife bursting with crime
deception and unforgettable writing and
psychonauts would be tim's follow-up
seven years later and the debut title of
his newly founded studio
double fine tim and his team who worked
on grim up to this point had
only made adventure games under the
umbrella of lucas lucasarts
the adventure genre was heavily focused
on story characters
exploration and at times uh less than
logical puzzle solving manny what are
you doing
just marking cards honey in its heyday
which was the mid to early
90s the adventure genre was very popular
but as time went on the market turned
into more action-centric games
and slower paced narrative driven ones
started to fade out with grim fandango a
masterpiece praised by critics
and loved by me being the nail in the
coffin for the genre because
it was a commercial failure for
lucasarts which in turn
caused the developer to move away from
the genre altogether
so when tim and his team left lucasarts
to start double fine
that was a pretty big gamble a new
studio a new ip
of course there was gonna be setbacks
what followed was years of a treacherous
development cycle
at one point microsoft was supposed to
publish a game but there was creative
differences then microsoft dropped the
deal but then sims maker himself will
wright came in and helped fund it
eventually majesco entertainment swooped
in to publish and after
years and years of development and weeks
of crunch
the game came out to be
a commercial failure reportedly selling
less than a hundred thousand copies
by the end of the year still like rim
despite its financial failure it
received critical acclaim for its
writing and imaginative design
and this should be no surprise to anyone
who has played a double fine game as
these are the defining characteristics
of the studio's dna
in psychonauts you play as ten-year-old
ras spun who ran away from the circus to
attend a whispering rock psychic summer
camp
a government training facility for
psychic secret agents
you will find yourselves on the path to
becoming international
secret agents in other words
psychonauts what ensues is a series of
twisting
mysteries from a creature in the lake to
brains being stolen to razz having to
grapple with his own
past and in order to save the camp and
himself
he must enter the minds of a wide array
of characters to progress
it is brilliant in fact everything about
this game conceptually
is brilliant its title screen brilliant
emotional baggage being literal baggage
brilliant mental cobwebs brilliant linda
brilliant and 16 years later that all
stands but not without some
growing pains however starting it up
again
yes it doesn't take long to see its age
like the pre-rendered cutscenes or
certain textures that didn't translate
well in our
hd world but if you squint in your eyes
a certain way you can look right past
its liver spots
but once my eyes got adjusted its
imperfections very quickly took a back
seat as i
once again became fully almost
distractingly engrossed by the
characters that inhabit
whispering rock psychic summer camp i
would never do that
i could never kill everyone
oh hi raz swirl trouble
there isn't a single moment where i felt
my time was wasted for exploring or i
wasn't rewarded for
going off the beaten path to see what
was behind a cabin or
hear conversations among campers often
revealing bizarre
subplots that only linger in passing
like elka's undying love to her ex
nils when in actuality nilsa's only
concern is spying on girls
you know that cabin is empty right duh
i'm practicing for tonight
when it's gonna be full a lady meanwhile
this dude is forever on the hunt for a
bear
while this cheer squad is seemingly up
to something really
really menacing
every character has a purpose in place
that makes the camp
feel lived in each of its characters
world concepts and mechanics
work in complete tandem whether it's
raz's past as a circus performer to
explain his gymnastic abilities
to not being able to swim due to fear
instilled by a supposed curse bestowed
upon his family by gypsies
or just the very concept that levels are
constructed and designed on the specific
character's psyche which is why sasha
9's mind is a perfectly organized white
cube or that coach oleanders as a
battlefield stricken landscape
it all makes sense and works within the
logic of psychonauts world
but that isn't to say that it isn't held
back in some other places
most specifically it's stiff arthritis
joints for a platformer controls aren't
the greatest
they aren't horrible in fact at times
they're perfectly passable
but adapting to the game's slightly
sticky platforming controls was the
biggest hurdle when returning to this
game
especially some of its combat and
nothing
is more defining of this game's
characteristics both
good and bad than its most iconic level
the milkman conspiracy later in the game
in order to bypass a gate into an
abandoned asylum
you have to enter the mind of one of its
patients boyd
who is a conspiracy theorist fixated on
a milkmaid it's all about the milk man
can't you see is this like one of those
3d paintings
i can never do those this level from top
to bottom is a feast of the game's
artistic originality
creative design and comical writing in
this level you'll walk through the
fragmented and disjointed mind of
boyd while disguising yourself and
blending in with the spies that inhabit
it
scouring for the milkman there's girl
scouts who whisper to bushes and
eyes are watching your every move it
truly instills an incredible eerie
feeling of being watched but it is also
obstructed by some combat encounters
that
the player is forced into which do more
to break the pacing and immersion than
it does to engross me further
but despite these shortcomings
psychonauts levels rarely repeat
themselves
with each one introducing a bespoke
mechanic and style that only exists
within it
from the roles switching kaiju level to
the luchador level
not to mention the abilities you gain
with progression it constantly kept
things engaging
every step of the way even though the
steps themselves can be
a little wonky overall no singular
mechanic is perfect
but the world you interact with traverse
and stay in during your visit to the
whispering rock psychic
summer camp is flawless
psychonauts was built on a series of
very big creative risks
whether that be disbanding from an
established institute like lucas arts
starting a new studio sticking to
creative integrity against seemingly all
odds
only for the game to initially come out
as a commercial flop
and yet here we are 16 years later with
a sequel on the way
due in part to a lofty fundraising
campaign
so for me beyond just being hugely
influential on me as a tween and
actually holding up pretty well today i
also kind of see it as a symbol for
artistic and creative integrity
in the games industry so for all of
these reasons
this is why psychonauts is a pretty big
deal
and worth your attention 16 years later
and besides it's on game pass so like
if you have an xbox and you have game
pass if you have pc
and game pass you don't really have an
excuse to
like to not try it and while you're at
it
just download grim fandango from me
please
okay thanks so much for watching i'm
current devina
this is megatron happy gaming see you
later
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
you